devo pulire tutti gli alunni che non
studiano le vostre dita
Oh mio Dio
oh ah ah ah ah ah
[Musica]
siamo tornati acqua
ma dove starà la maestra non lo so io
non l'ho vista neanche io l'ho vista
speriamo che non sia la maestra
dell'altra volta te la ricordi
Buongiorno
[Musica]
oggi vi metterò alla prova Avete
studiato inglese Sì sì io ho studiato io
ho studiato e tu hai studiato inglese
ho studiato tu un pochino ho studiato
e tu
se tu non hai studiato inglese e ti
rimetterò in prigione per una settimana
e dormirai qua a scuola
mi fa male la pancia posso tornare a
casa
Adesso vedi che ti è passato tutto il
mal di pancia
così almeno
stavo bene
tu schiaffi Spostati da lì Fammi mettere
a me Spostati Spostati carini
e veloce maestro guarda
Dammi questo è il mio
Io sì
Così impari è tutta colpa tua stupido
scienziato brutto puzzolente prima
Challenge con gli occhi bendati dovrete
pescare tre colori di pennarelli da
questa scatola avete le belle sul
bancone subito
messa ho messo la benda
sono pronto
[Musica]
ma cosa devo fare ma come si apre non ne
ho ascoltato
neanche ancora forse non ho capito bene
Però tutto buio continua a vederli più
niente ma proprio a me dovevo dare
questa ventola che brutta Ti devi
accontentare e seppiate ancora le tue
ossa
Anita Prendi tre colori
vediamo che colori sono
blu viola e nero dai non mi è andata
troppo male tranne il nero però sono dei
colori carini Dai venite i colori allora
dov'è qui
tre colori pronti
[Musica]
Verde Rosa e grigio va bene il grigio
non mi piace tantissimo però son belli
Comunque non è rosa quella è rosso ho
detto Rosa era rosso rosso
vediamo un po'
come usarlo non ho fatto
cos'è questo
[Musica]
formaggio
Ma che schifo ma è un casino che sicuro
Katia non schiappe così
il giallo il marrone cazzo
la principessa schiappe Ora tocca a te
cosa devo fare
Dove sono i colori
Ah colori che preferiscono c'è sempre il
van de mi piace moltissimo il grande e
poi c'è anche quello Turchese sono
proprio i colori che io amo Bellissimi
questi colori ora disegnerete il mio
ritratto se mi disegnerete male le
vostre dita
che la Challenge abbia inizio
[Musica]
Ok devo riuscire a disegnare la maestra
al meglio possibile devo farla il più
carino possibile e devo usare questi tre
colori inizio
[Musica]
proverò a farla molto carina così almeno
non mi taglia le dita
[Musica]
è arrivato il mio momento di vendicarmi
E userò questo colore
[Musica]
con questo colore io posso fare
qualunque arretrato
[Musica]
Se userete solo un colore le vostre dita
tempo scaduto
[Musica]
Ecco il ritratto che ti ho fatto Spero
che ti piaccia Un po' ti somiglia Ma
sembra Elsa chi Elsa
no ti somiglia un pochettino No
però devo dire è bello
quindi non mi toglierai le dita No Meno
male mi sono salvata Vitale Fammi vedere
il tuo disegno Questo è il mio disegno
Oh mio Dio che è brutta No no è maestra
bravissima l'ho anche scritto è
bravissima Ma è bruttissima
eh Questa è la tua punizione adatta
ora maestra Io ho fatto un capolavoro
l'ho fatta uguale uguale
se tu hai fatto la faccia di cacca vedi
cosa ti faccio
No non ho fatto la faccia di cacca Ci
mancherebbe altro e invece l'ho fatto
Ah ah ah ah ah
No no è il mio foglio maestro no no no
no no no no no ci ho messo tutti tanti
impegni significa questo
ma mi sembra
era tua punizione
in testa alta di nuovo che cosa vuole
fare che cosa vuole fare no no no no
maestra
Ma sempre in prigione finisco
Voglio sperare che il tuo disegno sarà
migliore
[Musica]
un attimo Secondo me
Mamma mia Che brutta
non è brutto ma non è così brutto molto
meglio di quello di Billy
sembri tu sembro mio non sembro io non
sembro io però un pochino
ero un pochino è vero sembro io Ora
visto che non ti sei impegnato Ti
taglierò la vita
visto che ti sei impegnato un po' così
io sono la maestra del thousand Quindi
adesso stai zitto
impara a farmi così brutta
questi bambini questa Challenge l'ha
vinta Anita
che ho disegnato Elsa almeno il mio
disegno non era schifoso come quello
degli altri io ho vinto la prima
Challenge speriamo di vincere anche la
seconda Ma voi avete lasciato un mi
piace nello scorso video vi ho detto che
se il video avessero aggiunto 5.000 mi
piace avremmo fatto un altro video con
la maestra cattiva se questo video
Invece raggiunge i 6000 mi piace faremo
un altro video con la maestra trita ossa
quindi cliccate mi piace qua sotto
adesso passiamo alla seconda Challenge
[Musica]
di inglese io scriverò la parola lavagna
e voi lo dovete disegnare chi sbaglia
avrà una penitenza Anita vieni alla
lavagna
disegna Wonder
[Musica]
Mamma mia che schifo
sembra un panino Aspetta Allora il
disegno meglio
[Musica]
Così impari a studiare Oh vi voglio
dietro i tuoi peli Ah ah ah ah
ahia
scappa via la lavagna
disegnato
difficile disegnare Però credo che ci
riuscirò
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutte le parti hai sbagliato scarpe hai
fatto un disegno schifoso Hai lasciato
significa ombretto E ora la tua
punizione sarà metterti l'ombretto
freddo
[Musica]
Che bello che soddisfacente
alza questa testa
Che bello
Sono sicuro che sarò bellissimo
sicuro
Ah ho finito il mio capolavoro tipo
vedere scarpe
[Musica]
ma sono bellissima
cosa bellissima se sei una capra Vai a
posto mamma mia
Bigli di non lavagna e muoviti
io ho studiato l'inglese disegna Shoes
Allora cuciniamo
Io lo sapevo assolutamente niente
[Applauso]
[Musica]
scarpe e siccome non avevi fatto questa
è la tua punizione
Ma che cosa sta facendo maestra
Che schifo
non mi sento tanto bene
questa era la scarpa più puzzolente al
mondo e ora vai a posto
[Applauso]
Ahia ahia devo pulire tutti gli alunni
che non studiano
la lavagna
[Musica]
io forse ho capito
bang bang Questa è quello che vuol dire
Cos'è questa cosa è sbagliato È un pezzo
vuol dire cerchietto non questa erba
questa erba ora la tua punizione sarà
metterti il cerchietto
una
femminuccia ora vai a posto dai su Forza
vai vai
[Musica]
questa parola di sicuro non indovinerà
bellino lavagna disegnati
però maestra aspetti Eh perché non
sembra poco qua Ci manca un pezzo forse
non l'ha scritto bene
[Musica]
fatto Ah ok sì è scritto meglio quindi
Poop può essere
forse lo so Vediamo se è questo
[Musica]
è un pupazzo
pupo un bambino che piange medio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma ero disegnata prima ora Questa è la
tua punizione
anzitutto Chiudi gli occhi e Siediti
chiudi
gli occhi
[Musica]
è una cosa dietro la schiena
cosa Controlla guarda un biglietto
no no no no nel senso No no no non l'ho
fatto io No veramente lo giuro non l'ho
fatto io Ah ah ah ah
Mi hai rubato
questa esplosione
abbassati
tutto finalmente Comunque ti devo dire
una brutta notizia sei bocciato anche
quest'anno
sì
Ah dimenticavo l'ultima cosa
Ah
finalmente sta zitta tutti e tre
quest'anno siete promossi
Rossi